programa número 65 de la siguiente lista
si m es un entero entre 1 y 10
incluyendo los entonces la mediana debe
ser
nos dicen que n debe estar entre 1
y 10 incluyendo los mayor igual a 1
menor o igual a 10
se refiere a la mediana no a la media la
mediana es el número medio vamos a
ordenar todos estos números vamos a
poner el más pequeño es 22 luego si 3
luego sigue el 44 después 5
después
y hasta aquí tengo mis números al que
sobre sn pero tengo que ver dónde lo
coloco lo que nos dicen es que el cne
podría estar en cualquier lugar de esta
lista puede ser un 1 o un 10 pero
también puede ser cualquier otro de
estos números pero antes de buscar un
lugar a nba mos cuál podría ser el
número medio si son aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
números el número medio debería estar
por acá ahora veamos qué pasa si yo
pongo n de este lado que n sea menor o
igual que 5 podría ser n uno o dos o
tres o cuatro o cinco si yo pongo n de
este lado cual sería la mediana
pues aquí tendría 1234 aquí 4 la mediana
sería 5 y qué pasa en el caso de que sea
mayor o igual que 6 podría tener en el
valor de 10 o cualquiera de estos otros
valores
tiene está en esta parte la mediana
sería la que tendría aquí bueno en este
caso yo no estaría hasta la n de este
lado uno dos tres cuatro números acá uno
dos tres cuatro números acá la mediana
podría ser seis
incluso n podría ser seis pero estamos
viendo para aquí por la posición en
donde se quedaría el número intermedio
número medio entonces yo puedo decir que
si n es menor igual a 5 entonces la
mediana mediana
mediana será 5
n es mayor o igual que 6 entonces la
mediana
será 6
cualquiera de estos casos será correcto
y esta es nuestra opción b
siguiente problema problema número 66
tenemos esta suma 47 más n 23 más 162 y
esto nos da como resultado mil 222 si
este resultado de la suma es correcta
cuál sea el valor de n más uno hagamos o
tratemos de hacer la zona 7 más 13 10 +
2 es 12 entonces aquí tenemos el 2
llevamos una esto sería uno más su más
dos más 61 269 nos quedaría esta parte
como un
+ 9 y esto debe ser igual a algo que
termine con 2
aquí no se puede haber algún otro
elemento
qué número sumado a 9 nos da algo
terminado con 2 el más cercano y lo más
cercano que puedo tener aquí es 12 que
esto sea un 12 para que esto sea un 12
tendríamos que sumar 39 y en este caso
tendría que ser igual a 3 ok entonces si
esto fuera igual a 3 aquí nos daría 12
llevaríamos bueno pondremos 2 aquí
deberíamos 1 y en este otro caso uno más
cuatro cn uno sería uno más 45 + 16
seria en m6 igual aquí tenemos el valor
completo igual a 12
para que esto sea 12 n tiene que ser
igual a 12 6 y 6 n ser igual a 6 por lo
tanto lo que nos preguntan de n más 1
será igual a 6 + 3
igual a 9 que esta es nuestra opción b
pasemos al siguiente problema problema
número 67 este sea un poquito denso pero
leamos si una acción se vende tres meses
después de su compra la siguiente
fórmula relaciona pe de ese hierro donde
p es el precio al que se compró la
acción de es la cantidad de dividendos
recibidos ese es el precio al que se
vendió la acción y r es la ganancia de
la inversión como un porcentaje
si es rosa compro una acción a 400
dólares recibió un dividendo de 5
dólares y vendió la acción a 420 dólares
tres meses después de su compra cuál fue
la ganancia de su inversión de acuerdo a
la fórmula esa es la fórmula que nos
dicen y nos dicen que se la formula
cuando la acción se vende tres meses
después y rosa vendió tres meses después
de su compra su acción así que esa
fórmula aplica vamos a anotar los datos
de el precio al que se compró es igual a
viviendo es igual a 5 que aquí nos dicen
y ese es el precio de venta de la acción
fue de 420 ahora sustituimos esto es la
fórmula de va a ser igual a 400
por 5 más 420 menos 400
entre 400
ok simplificamos esto 5 420 425
400 esto va a ser igual a 400 por 1 425
400 son 25 entre 400
esto de aquí se va y nos queda que
recibe la 25 y como es porcentaje base
el 25%
y este es lo que está en nuestra opción
pasemos al siguiente problema
las temperaturas en grados celsius que
por cierto siempre es bueno decir grados
celsius o centígrados pero nunca a decir
grados centígrados porque es una
aberración ok después de esto ya esta
nota cultural seguimos leyendo el
problema reportados a las seis de la
mañana en cierto país son 10 5 - 2 - 15
y 15 cuál es la mediana de dichas
temperaturas recuerden que la mediana es
diferente a la media la mediana es el
número de en medio así que comencemos
ordenando las temperaturas la más
pequeña es menos 5 menos 5
luego sigue menos 2
menos dos después menos uno
- 1 después 5
5 luego 10
y finalmente 15 ya es tan enorme aquí
hay algo interesante de la mediana si no
hay un valor justo en el medio por
ejemplo aquí tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 elementos
o sea que no tengo un número que esté
justo a la mitad de estos elementos aquí
debería estar el número medio pero no
tengo cuando esto sucede lo que hacemos
es
los dos valores que están cercanos a la
mitad que es este menos 1 y este 5 y lo
que hago con ellos es sumar los menos 15
y encontrar el promedio de estos dos
osea dividirlo entre 2 eso es igual a 4
entre dos igualados este 2 es la mediana
de este conjunto de números que es mi
opción
bien pasemos al último problema de este
vídeo número 69 sigue por 3 x 52 es
igual a james y es diferente de 0 cuál
va a ser el valor de x
vamos a dividir todo esto entre sí
divido todo eso entre james esto entre
ella y esto entre me va a quedar 3x
porque esto se van 6 x menos 5 entre 2
/ lleva a ser 1 ahora multiplicamos todo
por 2 2 por esto esto por 2 éstos se van
3 x 5 igualados
sumamos 5 en ambos lados aquí
5 + 5 éstos se van 3x igual a 7
dividimos todo entre 3 entre 3 nos queda
esto se va x igual a 7 tercios
qué es la opción número 0 y nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo